Speaker 1: All right. Let's get right into it.
Very important. 2022 race Fetterman versus Oz,
Pennsylvania Senate television quack. Dr.
Mehmet Oz is the Republican Senate nominee
in Pennsylvania. Running against him is
the Democratic Lieutenant Governor, John
Fetterman. Much has been made by the Oz people
about Fetterman having a stroke and Fetterman
needing special medical accommodations for debates
and all of these horrible, different things. And
increasingly, Oz has just looked really like a bad
guy. And there is a new poll that looks very bad
for Mehmet Oz, but we try to pay attention to the
average of recent polls and never focus too much
on any one poll. But let's go in order. New poll
Fetterman ahead of Oz with a double digit lead,
writes Newsweek. When you look at the details,
this is a new Marist poll published earlier this
week. 51% of registered voters in Pennsylvania
support Fetterman, compared to 41% who support Oz.
7% undecided. This is a good number for Fetterman.
However, if you go to likely voter I'm sorry,
definite voters in November. Oz gets 44% with
Fetterman 51 and 4% undecided. However, when we
look at the averages of recent polls, you see that
Fetterman is lead is an average of four and a half
points. Again, we want to see this as glass glass
half full, or do we want to see this as glass
half empty? And the questions are always very
similar. Well, the glass half full perspective is
Fetterman is winning and it's outside the margin
of error. The glass half empty is how on earth?
Does a TV doctor from a different state who
has no business even running, never mind being
in the Senate, have an average of 44% of the
expected Pennsylvania electorate saying, Yeah,
I'm going to go with the quack TV doctor from
Jersey. Glass half full, glass half empty. You
tell me. The important thing is assume absolutely
nothing and make sure that you vote. There are
important deadlines in Pennsylvania. The deadline
for in-person registration at local election
offices is October 24th. That's three and a half
weeks away. The deadline to register online is
October 24th, and the deadline to register
by mail is. Your request must be received
by October 24th. So October 24th is the important
number in Pennsylvania. Now for absentee ballots,
you must request your ballot no later than
November one. By 5 p.m. it must be received your
return ballot by mail, meaning when you vote must
be received November 8th by 8 p.m. That's when
polls close in Pennsylvania. If you don't send it
early enough for it to be received by that time,
it's not going to be counted. And then lastly, to
turn in your ballot in person or vote in person,
it is November 8th by 8 p.m. polls close
8 p.m. on election day in Pennsylvania.
Extraordinarily important election when we
ask the question, as many of us often do.
On which state might Democratic
control of the Senate hinge?
One of the most likely outcomes is that if indeed
democratic control hinges on only one state. That
state will be Pennsylvania. So these midterms, we
never want to say races don't matter. Of course,
tons of races matter, but both gubernatorial
and senatorial. Pennsylvania is dramatically
important. I hope all of our Pennsylvania
listeners are registered or you're going to
get registered by October 24th and you're going
to vote. Not only is the Senate vote important,
but I will again take the opportunity to remind
you the gubernatorial race, and we will be
covering a debate between SHAPIRO and Mastriano,
the Republican nominee in Pennsylvania for the
governor's race. Doug Mastriano yes, he has a
history of dressing like a Confederate soldier.
It's disgusting. Yeah, he's vile. Disgusting
guy. Fine. But put that aside for a second. He is
overtly a guy who will try to steal Pennsylvania
for the Republican presidential candidate in 2024,
no matter who wins. He has said he was in D.C.
on January 6th. He has said he believes Trump
actually won in Pennsylvania even though he
didn't, he didn't get more votes. But somehow
Mastriano thinks Trump won. If in 2024 you have a
tight election in Pennsylvania and the Democratic
presidential nominee wins, if mastriano is the
governor, he will try to steal those electoral
votes for the Republican. Even if the Republican
didn't win, I don't know how else to say it. I
don't know how else to explain it to people.
This is an emergency in Pennsylvania. I think
I've said enough. Register. Make sure you know
where your polling places. Do not forget to vote.